ahora tenemos nueve pelotas listas nueve
pelotas son idénticas al menos en
apariencia tenemos ocho de ellas que
tienen un mismo peso y una de ellas no
sabemos cuál es un poquito más pesada no
mucho es un poquito más pesada que el
resto y mi pregunta para ustedes sería
cuál es la cantidad mínima de veces que
podemos usar esta balanza que tenemos
aquí para saber definitivamente cuidado
esto es importante definitivamente cuál
es la pelota más pesada no estamos
hablando de suerte tiene que ser un
hecho que esa es la pelota más pesada no
así como que tomo esta y la peso y
resulta ser la más pesada no es un hecho
que esta es la pelota más pesada y
tendremos esta balanza para poder
descubrir cuál es la cantidad mínima de
veces que podemos usar esta balanza para
saber cuál es la pelota más pesada
recuerda que requerimos el 100% de
certeza
de que después de esta cantidad de veces
que tú me dirás tendremos sí o sí la
pelota más pesada o la respuesta
correcta te invito a que hagas una pausa
y pienses cuál sería este número de
cualquier manera más adelante te voy a
dar un par de pistas suponiendo que
pausas te y el vídeo te voy a dar la
primera pista
mi primer pista es que con dos veces que
utilicemos esta balanza podrás tener
certeza de cuál es la pelota correcta te
invito a que pongas una pausa y lo
intentes o que hiciste tu pausa te voy a
dar la segunda pista la segunda pista es
que cada mensaje podemos descartar dos
terceras partes de las pelotas que son
candidatas
se la repito en cada pensar podremos
descartar dos tercios de las pelotas que
siguen siendo candidatas una pausa más y
después empezaremos a trabajarlo juntos
vamos a trabajar este problema o
acertijo como algunas veces los llaman
que suelen utilizarlo en entrevistas de
trabajo y te diré paso por paso cómo
llegaremos a los dos mensajes para tener
la cantidad correcta lo que haremos es
dividir en tercios la cantidad que
tenemos de pelotas en este caso tenemos
nueve pelotas y si lo dividimos en
tercios tendremos tres grupos
1 2 3
lo primero que haremos es ya que tenemos
esta división por tercios pensaremos un
primer tercio vamos a ponerlo con otro
color
este primer tercio lo pensaremos en este
lado de la báscula mientras que este
segundo lo pensaremos de este lado
y entonces podemos llamar que nuestro
primer paso
será comparar
tres pelotas
una vez que tengamos esto vamos a poder
tener tres posibles soluciones las tres
posibles soluciones serán
las siguientes
en la primera pudiéramos decir que
tengamos un balance
si este grupo de pelotas pesa
exactamente lo mismo que este grupo de
pelotas entonces tendremos con certeza
que la pelota pesada se encuentra en
este último que dejamos fuera otra de
las opciones es
que el lado izquierdo
se vaya hacia abajo lo que indicaría que
en este grupo se encuentra la pelota más
pesada vamos a poner izquierda
es más pesado
y finalmente y finalmente la última
posibilidad de respuesta es que el lado
derecho se vaya hacia abajo indicando
que en el lado derecho tenemos la pelota
más pesada y con ello lo pondremos
derecho más pesado
el lado derecho ha sido más pesado lo
que indicaría que ahí está la pelota ese
sería nuestro primer paso nuestro
segundo paso implicaría pensar el grupo
de tres pelotas que haya resultado con
mayor peso
digamos que llamemos a este grupo 1
grupo 2 o grupo 3
en este caso seleccionaremos el grupo
que nos resultó más pesado y afuera que
si fue en el balance tomaríamos el grupo
aquí la pelota más pesada estaría en el
grupo 3
grupo 3 tienen
la pelota
más pesada
en este caso si se va hacia la izquierda
significaría que la pelota se encuentra
en el grupo 1
escribamos lo aquí grupo uno tiene
la pelota
más pesada
y si se nos va hacia la derecha
tendríamos que el grupo 2 tendría la
pelota más pesada vamos a escribirlo
también grupo 2
tiene
la pelota
pesada
perfecto con eso sabríamos entonces qué
grupo será el siguiente a pesar podemos
llamar entonces que tenemos cubierto el
primer paso y entonces haríamos un
segundo paso una vez que tenemos
seleccionado alguno de estos grupos pues
podemos pesar una pelota en cada uno de
los lados dejando fuera una de estas
vamos a hacer lo más gráfico pensemos
que se encuentra en este grupo 2 ok
entonces mandaremos esta pelota
a la izquierda esta pelota a la derecha
y dejaremos fuera esta tercera pelota
por lo tanto esta vez estaríamos
haciendo un pesaje de una pelota
respecto a una pelota y entonces
tendríamos exactamente las tres
posibilidades de respuesta
qué serían las siguientes
en la primera pues que quedarán
exactamente balanceados y lo llamaremos
balance
lo que nos indicaría que la pelota más
pesada es esta que quedó fuera si se va
hacia la izquierda
entonces tendríamos toda la certeza que
la pelota que está del lado izquierdo es
la más pesada que en este caso sería
esta y si se va a la derecha
sabríamos con exactitud que la pelota
más pesada es justo esta que se
encuentra en el lado derecho de nuestra
balanza este es un principio básico con
el cual ustedes ya pueden resolver este
tipo de acertijos y muchas veces lo
utilizan en entrevistas de trabajo y a
veces les gusta jugar nos algunas
trampas normalmente nos pueden poner
números mucho más grandes que tal 27
pelotas o qué tal 81 pelotas a veces
incluso hasta nos quitan pelotas por
ejemplo aquí nos pueden poner solo 8 y
no nos dejan un múltiplo así muy limpio
y muy claro de 3 y cuando nos hacen esto
lo que buscan es como confundirnos y que
nosotros no pensemos en tercios tal vez
con múltiplos de 3 sería mucho más
sencillo sin embargo si tuviésemos 8
aquí pudiéramos tomar 3
este segundo grupo de tres y un último
de dos y simplemente hacer los pesajes
correspondientes hasta llegar a nuestra
respuesta correcta
bueno los invito a que ustedes hagan
justo estos ejercicios de 27 181 pelotas
o qué tal la de 8 pelotas y con esto
ustedes pueden desarrollar esta
habilidad justo con este principio que
descarta dos tercios de las pelotas que
nos quedan como candidatas
bueno pues espero que este vídeo haya
sido claro útil y práctico para ustedes